in a closed hearing in madrid the man at
the center of souring ties between
morocco and spain
testified by video link
outside the high court protesters
accused brahim ghali of having blood on
his hands
the leader of western sahara's
independence movement the polisario
front
is seen by morocco as a war criminal
he's currently receiving medical care
for covid19 in a hospital in northern
spain
his treatment in the countries enraged
the moroccan government
gali who's also the president of the
sarawi democratic arab republic
a self-declared state has been accused
of torture and genocide by bolisario
dissidents and human rights groups the
presiding judge will decide after he
completes his investigation
whether to charge or dismiss the
lawsuits against him
but rejected a prosecution request for
gali to be taken into custody
carly's lawyer said the accusations are
categorically untrue
president believes this lawsuit is
politically motivated to try
once again to undermine the dignity and
credibility of the saharari people
and their struggle towards
self-determination
western sahara is a disputed territory
the size of the united kingdom
mostly held by morocco since it passed
from spanish control in the 1970s
the algeria-backed polisario front
fought for independence for the sahrawi
people
until a ceasefire with morocco in 1991
manisa rawi have been living here in
exile in algeria's remote refugee camps
for decades
waiting for a un-backed referendum on
self-determination
but the votes been repeatedly postponed
and when the former u.s president donald
trump accepted moroccan sovereignty over
western
sahara the polisario front responded by
declaring
a new war with morocco
now spain says it's being punished for
allowing brahimgali to travel there for
treatment
after moroccan border guards allowed ten
thousand people to cross into the
spanish enclave of sayota
last month spain's prime minister pedro
sanchez accused the moroccan government
of blackmail
the diplomatic fallout continues
barker al jazeera